oh we're just talking tarantino there's  a video with a woman uh she's like why  the violence why the violence yeah  because i love it because it's great and  it sells tickets you [ __ ] leave us alone  who cares about we're coming out hard i  guess episodes you know what's funny  they're going to tarantino the way they  go at hockey  why the fighting by the fighting like if  you get it out that person complaining  about it is going to watch it yeah it's  the same thing like it's just like if  you're saying why the violence of that  guy you're not seeing any of his movies  then when he takes it out he'll just be  like it was sort of bland  not a good effort you know exactly